you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so
for this video I want to thank YouTube
user 105 for this it was their comment
in the previous video that made me aware
of the first automated passenger drone
this seemed like a pretty interesting
topic so I decided to do a video of it
and I'm going to discuss it a little bit
here let's get into it so recently it's
become fairly obvious that drones and
specifically the quadcopter industry is
blowing up but so far
consumer applications have been largely
limited to hobbyist flying racing and
filming this all changed at CES 2016
when a Chinese manufacturer Iran has
unveiled the world's first automated
passenger drone the e hyung 184 is a
fully electric aircraft that might sound
a little strange at first but electric
aircraft are indeed on the way
in fact Airbus just created the first
electric planes across the English
Channel in a late 2015 experiment the e
hung 184 is five point five meters long
takes two hours to charge and can fly
for 23 minutes at about 500 meters off
the ground it has a maximum altitude of
3.5 kilometers and a top speed of 101
km/h and a fun fact the flight
destination interface is actually a
Microsoft Surface tablet so where did
this drone come from the project was
started in 2011 when young CEO lost his
good friend in a private plane accident
and then later his helicopter teacher
from then on he Hung's found I wanted to
make sure that this new aircraft he was
going to make was going to be incredibly
safe so back to the e hung 180 for
automation is a great fit for this
application because it cuts out pilot
error planes much more complicated than
this drone are flown by
computer-controlled systems so this
isn't unusual at all the company states
that the navigation process is backed up
by a 24/7 real-time flight command
center and they think that that means
passengers have no need for a pilot's
license the downside though is that
Hung's case there are no manual controls
to take over in the event of an
emergency so there's a few remaining
questions that should be asked does the
drain have multiple redundant systems
that is if one mission critical element
fails does the craft keep aloft easily
for example if one propeller is damaged
can it be flown automatically with ease
I'd expect this to be the case but
there's no confirmation if an object
unexpectedly comes in front of the drain
how will it react I guess we've really
seen some progress in that field by
Intel and their drone so I guess we can
say basic flying and evasive action
might not be the issue but the real
issue could be if there's an event that
causes input data that confuses the
computer I think that's the most
dangerous thing in this situation but
according to e hyung the drone has been
tested hundreds of times over forests
sometimes and passengers but with these
things I guess you can never be too
careful
so the big question is this the future
of personal transport for me personally
I think the short answer is no not for
this vehicle anyway
the range is too short the battery life
is a major bottleneck and there's no way
of resuming manual control in the event
of an emergency and I don't think that
this aircraft would pass FAA regulations
anyway but that is by no means the full
story I think a craft like this has
potential for emergency respondents aid
and can be very beneficial in situations
where road access is limited but to
further this without going into
semantics the formula that e hyung has
here seems to be correct and if it's not
these guys it will be another company
that builds on the synergy of a
computer-guided and easy-to-use
passenger drone to create something
compelling it may be many years before
that happens but to me he hyung is the
start of something so the bigger
question is this the template for the
personal flying car that we've all been
promised all our lives I guess only time
will tell and which in these guys the
best and I watch this space closely for
any
babe thanks for watching guys that was
just a quick little video that I thought
Rd this has been to go-go you've been
watching cold fusion subscribe if you're
new and I'll see you guys again soon for
the next video oh and by the way the
Nikola Tesla video is still in
production so you guys can still keep
looking forward to that I hope to have
it out by the end of this month cheers
guys have a good one cold fusion if
we're thinking